all right here's the guy's got a
question let's get into it here's our
first King under sting it hey guys
what's going on she's John from Los
Angeles we're doing his little podcast
big fan so I got a king under sting it
for you guys so it's been recently
released that they're gonna have Nicolas
Cage played Joe exotic and the scripted
series that's coming out and I'd love to
know what you guys think and can Nicolas
Cage pull this off can he portray the
legendary Joe exotic what do you guys
think man I'd love to know King at her
sting it Nicolas Cage playing Joe exotic
and the scripted series Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young and bright I
love me some Nicolas Cage he really
doesn't miss and she started going broke
to his body like castles and snakes and
[ __ ] yeah they start doing some bad
movies but this was kind of he's gonna
knock this out the park I was hoping to
be Dax Shepard
I feel like you've been a really good
Joe exotic oh yeah kind of has that like
white-trash vibe you know yeah yeah yeah
accent seemed a little too Nicolas
Cage's could actually really make it
amazing that's the thing like Dax I
think I make it kind of good like it'll
be interesting
yeah but cage could really leave that I
mean he might be able to make an amazing
man
yeah Nicolas Cage is the art team right
he's an artiste broke and my boys thick
though I've seen him lately he's Jack
not like no not Jack Nick he's getting
oh he put on weight yeah fat well maybe
that's not a thick with three C's a
thick right K okay yeah and then did you
see when he's get the last time I saw
him outside of a movie he was didn't get
married and him and his wife or Fiat
they started arguing wine in Vegas and
she stormed off he said trouble in love
man he's at trouble in love he's in my
favorite movie family man he's probably
one of the 13 or probably 15 best actors
ever hands down face off down Ivan same
face off take your face off really think
if you and I exchange faces that's face
off dude well that's all those things
that Brian monarch does also yeah you
ready what was the one he was in with
Dave Chappelle Louis Kate he had the
long hair you know oh [ __ ] dude Connor
Connor Connor haven't seen their home is
chapelle encounter mm-hmm
yes he put the bunny back in the box
uh-huh they beats it kills the guy
that's told you about touch the bunny uh
is it a real bunny no it's his daughter
stuffed toy
I think his cage is in this John
Malkovich showing that Cyrus the virus
being rain already touches oh Dave
Chappelle are in ball and he kills him
he gets stuck in the poor on the wing
boo shameless Sheba Sheree huh grade in
it to Danny Trejo and he's in every
movie but well I love that man I love it
I say King and I think Cage is gonna
knock out of the park
okay I can't think of a better one that
Shepherd is my only go to but that was a
solid one right there Nicolas Cage is
[ __ ] good
[Music]